triple-a estimates nearly 43 million
Americans are traveling on this Memorial
Day weekend flags are everywhere more
than 37 million of them are on the
highway today new research shows many of
those drivers are profoundly distracted
by you guessed it your phone when
they're rolling past first responders
the results are increasingly deadly Kris
Van Cleave is on the road outside
Washington DC with more on this story
Kris this is very concerning good
morning to you good morning Gail a
shocking number here is we're about to
drive by a first responder on the side
of the road 16 percent of drivers admit
to either hitting or nearly hitting an
emergency vehicle or first responder on
the side of the road now 21 first
responders have died on the side of the
road so far this year that makes 2019 on
pace to be deadlier than last year and
we got to warn you some of the video
you're gonna see can be hard to watch
this moment changed Florida Highway
Patrol trooper methyl Patel's life last
December he doesn't remember but you can
see him here on the shoulder of
Interstate 95 working an accident
despite closing a traffic lane as a
safety buffer troopers say a suspected
distracted driver lost control patel
throws another man to safety right
before being hit himself a different
feeling definitely seeing Gras almost
got killed definitely a weird feeling
this is only the second time patel's
been back to the accident scene do you
feel lucky to have survived that you've
seen the video now
I have feel extremely lucky I have seen
people
yeah pretty much died from this new
research from the National Safety
Council found 71 percent of drivers
copped to taking photos and texting
while driving by emergency workers
that's nearly triple the 24 percent who
admitted to doing it under normal
driving conditions 60 percent admitted
to posting to social media two-thirds
have emailed about what they're driving
by what surprised us most about the
study was the magnitude of people who
are really exercising very dangerous
behavior they're adding another level of
exposure to these first responders forty
first responders were killed on the side
of the road last year up 60 percent from
2017 and so far this year 21 have died
including 10 police officers 14 officers
were hit and killed in all of 2018
heading to a traffic accident Miami Fire
Captain Steve Perez says as soon as they
flip on the lights and sirens drivers
behave differently every call you see
people paying more attention to their
phones in the road is it that common
sure it's very I would venture to say
it's very common to see somebody either
on their phone
or taking their phone out to try to
videotape or get a snap over what's
going on I have seen it where they pull
out their phone outside the window start
taking pictures not paying attention the
road
we rode with trooper Patel as he hit the
road in his patrol car for the first
time since the accident last December
did you have some nerves yes sir in the
morning but I still have the butterfly
in my belly you know whenever you see
the brake squeeze really hard you're
always going to go back to be like is it
coming towards my way or not trooper
Patel is still recovering but hopes to
be back on full duty and responding to
calls on the side of the road here in
the coming months now he says bottom
line just put the phone down when you're
driving Tony
Chris thank you put the phone down or
have someone else do the driving while
you do your report rubbernecking has
always been a problem but social media
is taking it to a completely different
level as people want to take pictures
and so other people I don't understand
what you want to do with that picture
they want to send it to TV outlets TV we
should not do that say that we haven't I
mean we all know what we're supposed to
do we all know the right thing to do but
everybody thinks just one more too
little text one more picture you just
you cannot do it and everyone thinks
they're better driver and less
distracted in fact they are right you
know exactly everybody thinks they're
above average